[Musique]
un mois et demi à prévenir Anne les
effets du cyclone sont encore visibles
dans la bananerie de Frank souris
Lavergne le 6 mars des rafales à plus de
250 km/h ont anéanti sa récolte soit 3
tonnes de fruits en cours de maturation
une catastrophe certes mais aussi
peut-être le départ d'un projet innovant
nous voulons pas tout jeter etc je me
suis dit je vais essayer de faire de la
farine mais donc j'ai commencé à faire
des essais de séchage et en parallèle
j'ai contacté Gaby levier noir qui a
créé un réseau autour de de cette de
cette idée là de faire de la farine avec
les bananes qui étaient tombées au
cyclone et voilà de contact en contact
qu'on a mis un petit groupe en place qui
a permis de passer quelques bananes
vertes en farine
pour faire un essai et peut-être voir
s'il y a quelque chose à faire pour la
suite quoi mais l'idée est née voilà de
en voyant toutes les bananes au sol
après nirrane
participe activement à ce projet en
transformant les bananes en farine ce
docteur en chimie dirige un laboratoire
de recherche il préside aussi le cluster
native NC objectif découvrir et
promouvoir de nouvelles filières
produits naturels la farine de banane
verte pourrait en faire partie mais il
faut d'abord mettre au point les process
première étape la préparation des fruits
donc voilà le les bananes sont bien
sèches on obtient des chips de bananes
de bien sèche ici qu'on va pouvoir
réduire en farine grâce à un petit
moulin un petit broyeur à végétaux et je
vais vous faire une démonstration
rapidement il faut 5 kg de bananes pour
faire 1 kg de farine un rendement 4 fois
inférieur à celui du blé mais qu'importe
l'essentiel est de tester ce nouveau
produit ses défauts comme ses qualités
ça c'est le produit fini qui nous reste
à mettre en sachet après
qui est vraiment très stimulant là c'est
de travailler avec les producteurs de
bananes en direct qui ont un intérêt qui
sont très intéressés très demandeurs
pour créer ces nouveaux produits on
travaille également avec la décale et
puis Gabriel leviennois et les et le
Pacifique food là notamment pour tout la
transformation et les applications
finales de ces produits la
caractérisation de des valeurs
nutritionnelles de la farine donc on est
vraiment au travail vraiment main dans
la main avec tous les tous les acteurs
du la chaîne de la valeur et ça c'est
vraiment très enthousiasmant très
stimulant de la farine de banane verte
soit mais pour quel usage le chef
Gabriel le vieux noir test ce nouveau
produit local à toutes les sauces son
coup de cœur les crêpes
[Musique]
première crêpes pareil là j'ai pris un
lait végétal on peut prendre du lait
normal deux œufs 30 g de sucre 30 g
d'huile
75 g de farine de banane vert avec un
petit une cuillère à café de poudre à
lever et on va les mixer
[Musique]
c'est une farine qui a un pouvoir
d'absorption assez important même moi je
suis pas très familier avec ce genre de
farine nous on a plus l'habitude de
travailler avec de la farine de blé et
justement là c'est l'alternative pays
[Musique]
producteur juste au transformateur et à
la personne qui commercialise pour
organiser finalement toute la logistique
toute la chaîne moi je suis juste en
bout de course et l'idée c'est de faire
c'est de faire une recette pour
promouvoir ce produit mais pour avoir la
glisser le temps de s'exprimer et que
finalement on est les bonnes recettes et
qu'on comprenne comment il fonctionne
place salé ou sucré la farine de banane
verte offre de nombreuses possibilités
ça c'est un cake
avec de la patate douce
et puis un petit une petite sauce au
fromage blanc et concombre en plat
principal j'ai fait une lasagne en mode
Colombo de saumon des dieux là j'ai fait
une pas limitation des Toulous enfin des
symboloro ou dis-moi
un petit dessert tout simple fois de
testeuse c'est savoureux fois d'experts
en nutrition c'est bon aussi pour la
santé
elle est particulièrement adaptée aux
personnes qui sont en surpoids ou qui
souffrent de diabète parce que un index
glycémique qui est très bas et en plus
de ça elle va être efficace pour tout ce
qui est inflammation du corps donc faut
penser toutes les maladies
inflammatoires comme la goutte arthrite
polyarthrite enfin voilà
elle va aussi renforcer nos défenses
immunitaires
elle va aussi être très efficace pour
tout ce qui est diarrhée
et puis c'est un super aliment elle est
encore plus nutritif que la banane la
banane mûre donc vraiment très adapté
pour les sportifs les enfants et puis
même pour les personnes âgées
d'innombrables qualités mais un gros
défaut son prix dans ce magasin bio la
farine de banane verte locale se vend
1750 francs les 500 g donc c'est un
produit très peu demandé nous a nos
diffusons quand même la fiche technique
quand on peut la voir on la diffuse pour
essayer de proposer aux clients des
substituts aux farines normales les
utilisations pour ce produit après pour
l'instant
c'est une vente tout doucement le temps
que ça se fasse connaître cet essai ni
Rome comme on l'appelle il permet de
voir un petit peu quel serait le retour
des consommateurs
et voilà il faut qu'on voit par la suite
ce qu'on pourrait faire je pense qu'il
serait intéressant c'est de construire
quelque chose pas que autour de la
farine de bananes vertes et qui permet
de faire des farines de plusieurs
produits différents et aussi aux besoins
de la banane Bertrand ou comment un
cyclone dévastateur nous permet de faire
un pas de plus vers l'autosuffisance
alimentaire